In today's ground lesson from the free
pilot training channel, we'll be
discussing the heading indicator and
explaining how it works.
The heading indicator, which is also
known as a directional gyro, is one of
the six primary flight instruments.
These are often referred to as a pilot's
six-pack. Now, the heading indicator is
one of the three gyroscopic instruments
and that means it uses the principles of
a gyroscope to operate. We'll talk about
that more in just a minute. Now, when it
comes to navigation and situational
awareness, the heading indicator is one
of the best tools you have available.
But with that in mind, let's take a look
at the Federal Aviation Regulations.
Specifically, I want to look at the VFR
day minimum equipment requirements. Now,
while we do need this instrument if we
want to fly IFR, you can see here that
we don't actually need this instrument
if we want to fly under visual flight
rules. But check this out, we do need a
magnetic direction indicator. And that's
just a fancy name for the magnetic
compass. So, why don't we fly off of
this thing instead of using the heading
indicator? Well, the first reason is
that when you use a magnetic compass, it
seems to operate backwards. For example,
let's say you're facing directly north
on a 360 heading. If you want to make a
turn to 330, you'll need to make a left
turn. But notice, the compass seems to
indicate that you'll need to make a
right turn to intercept a 330 heading.
Now, when you do make your turn, the
compass will move in the opposite
direction of your travel. And that's
because your airplane is on the outside
of that compass. But by using gyroscopic
principles, we're able to put the
airplane inside of the compass rose on a
heading indicator. And that allows us to
fix this problem. Then, in addition to
this, the mag compass is subject to dip
errors, turning errors, acceleration
errors, and several other things that
we'll discuss in detail in a future
lesson. Now that we know why we use a
heading indicator, let's talk about how
it works for a little bit. As I
mentioned before, the heading indicator
uses gyroscopic principles. Let's talk
about that for a minute.
Have you ever tried to balance a bicycle
while the bicycle's not moving forward?
It seems like it's impossible, right?
And if you pedal slowly, it's still
pretty wobbly. But once you start
gaining speed, the faster you go, the
easier it is to balance. And that's
because as the wheels turn more quickly,
they want to continue in the direction
they're going. And that makes the wheels
more resistant to outside forces. And
that means they're more rigid and more
resistant to wobbling.
This principle is known as rigidity in
space. Now, let's talk about how we use
this in the heading indicator. First,
let's zoom way in to take a look at the
actual gyro inside the heading
indicator. In order to create rigidity
in space, we need to get this thing
spinning somehow. Now, in some
airplanes, we use electric motors to do
this. But on most training aircraft, we
use the suction from the vacuum system
to create this movement. Let's take a
look at this really basic schematic of
the vacuum system in a training
aircraft. Now, you don't have to
memorize this thing or anything. I just
want you to see that if you're not
getting good suction on your vacuum
system, the gyro inside your heading
indicator may not be spinning the way it
needs to in order to work properly. If
that gyro's not spinning, you're not
getting rigidity in space, which means
your heading indicator isn't accurate.
Okay, so now we have the gyro rotor
spinning on its axis by using suction
from the vacuum system. Then, we have
two rings which surround the gyro rotor.
These rings, which are called gimbals,
allow the aircraft to move around the
gyro rotor without affecting its
position in space. These gimbals are
then mounted to the inside surface of
the heading indicator. And they're
mounted so that when the aircraft makes
a turn, the gyro is able to maintain its
position in space. The gyro is then
connected to a gear, which is also
connected to smaller gears, which
ultimately drive the heading indicator.
Then, as the aircraft turns, the gyro
maintains its position in space, while
these gears ultimately turn the compass
card to match the gyro while the
aircraft is turning. Now, most heading
indicators don't know which direction
north is, and that's because most of
these don't receive any kind of magnetic
signal. It's actually up to the pilot to
align the heading indicator with a
magnetic compass. We call this slaving
the heading indicator, and you can do
this by pushing this little button on
the heading indicator. By pushing this
button, the compass card is then
disconnected from the gears which run to
the gyro. Then, by rotating this button,
the compass card also rotates until it's
aligned with the magnetic compass on the
proper heading. So, I've already aligned
my heading indicator with my compass.
Why doesn't it just stay that way? And
the answer is because of something
called precession.
If we take a closer look at the inside
of this heading indicator, there's a lot
of moving parts here. Any one of these
parts that are able to move, like these
gimbals or gears, are subject to
friction. And this friction eventually
causes the heading indicator to drift
from its set position. And this drift is
known as precession. The other problem
is actually caused by the rotation of
the earth. Depending where you are on
the globe, it rotates at about 15° per
hour. And what might have been north at
the beginning of your flight, after an
hour, might be slightly different. And
that's why you want to reslave your
heading indicator every time you do a
run-up and about every 10 to 15 minutes
in flight. Just remember, when you're in
the air, the airplane needs to be in
straight and level flight in order to be
as accurate as possible. Now, on newer
aircraft with digital flight
instruments, the heading indicator often
comes in the form of a horizontal
situation indicator or HSI. Now, the way
these look to the pilot is really
similar, but the way these operate is
quite a bit different. In these
aircraft, a device called a magnetometer
senses the earth's lines of magnetic
flux. It then relates this information
to the aircraft's attitude and heading
reference system. This is also called
AHRS. This device then routes the
heading to the primary flight display or
PFD so the pilot can use this
information in flight. Because the
magnetometer is constantly sensing and
sending updated heading information,
there's no longer a need to reslave the
heading indicator on this device.
Hey, I hope you got something really
good out of this video. If you did,
would you hit that like button for me?
Also, please consider subscribing if you
haven't already. I've got lots more
videos and lots more coming. Speaking of
that, check this one out right here. I'm
sure you'll like it. See you.
Good brief calling safe position.